Beyonce looking flawless in a miniskirt
for a date night with jay-z after
revealing the first pics of their
newborn twins
[Music]
the 35 year old singer and her hubby
enjoyed a parents night out in Los
Angeles on Thursday attending the
listening party for rapper Vic Mensa's
debut album The Autobiography showcase
queen bee slayed in a cream-colored
miniskirt and sky-high heels while Jay
kept it casual in a baseball cap and
denim jacket at the event the rapper
spoke to the crowd about the 24 year old
musician who is signed to his label Roc
Nation you love a song you don't cream
to it have a good time that's what we
have an insider tells et that Beyonce
was stationed in a roped off corner but
most guests didn't even realize she was
there
later the two hit up Italian eatery John
and Vinny's for dinner with Kelly
Rowland and Beyonce's mom Tina Knowles
Lawson somehow the songbirds still found
time to break the internet sharing the
first pic of the couple's newborn twins
Sir Andrew me
[Applause]